- So wait, you ask them,
is it three questions?
All your guests, do you start
- Okay, so all my
guests, I like to do this
kind of subconscious test
that tells you sort of
- Wait, do it to me.
- I'm gonna do it to you.
- I love games.
- I'm not gonna tell you the end of it.
- So, if you're dating someone,
interviewing a new friend,
interviewing a new
coworker, this is a test
that helps you figure out
sort of who someone is
on a subconscious level.
So the first thing I'm gonna do is
- Oh, I am nervous.
- You should be.
I'm gonna ask you your favorite animal,
don't say Henry.
Don't say your dog, cause
that's what I wanna do,
I wanna say my dog.
- I wasn't gonna say my dog.
- I wanna say my dog,
I wanna say my horse.
Your favorite animal,
the one that you admire.
- The wolf.
- Wolf, that's a great one.
And three characteristics about a wolf.
Like, why you like them.
- I like 'em cause they're strong,
I like 'em cause they're fast,
and I like'em cause they travel in packs.
I like a buddy system.
- I love it, okay, that's genius.
The second thing is your
favorite article of clothing,
and it doesn't have to be
something you're wearing.
I was like oh, like a ballgown,
is it a pair of socks,
I ended up doing a hoodie,
cause they're like classic,
they're warm, they're sort of
gender-neutral, I like that.
Like, what would be your
favorite article of clothing?
- Jeans.
- Jeans, great, they are
- Well, mine are stretchy.
(laughs)
(applause)
Mine are very stretchy.
- You're miss pregnancy lady.
- You know what, I wore
them when I was pregnant,
and I thought about it afterwards,
but then I was like, this is too much,
you should stop eating and workout.
- The ones like with
the tire around the top?
- It's all elastic in the front, no.
No, I like regular
jeans, I'm a jeans girl,
but I like 'em because, they are,
they kind of, they're like second skins.
So I like that.
- They're classic maybe?
- And I'm a mom, and I'm
running around all the time,
and then we have a ranch in Montana,
so you don't really wear
ballgowns in Montana.
It's a little weird.
- And then your favorite body of water,
it can be a swimming
pool, a river, a lake,
I picked the New River in West Virginia
cause I used to spend time there as a kid.
- I would say river, well
I named my daughter River,
so I better like it.
- And three characteristics of a river.
I picked that too, so it was like.
- Oh, I like that they
connect all bodies of water,
I've heard.
- They're connected,
sometimes they're rough,
sometimes they're not, like
- Yes, but I like a rushing river.
I like the sound of it, it's calming.
- Okay, so, and I'm gonna tell
you what all of this means.
- Okay, I am ready.
How screwed up am I?
- It's not that bad, believe it or not.
- Okay, it is.
- Your favorite animal
is how you see yourself.
Wolf, what was it?
- Strong, fast, and I
travel in packs, yes, I do.
(applause)
- And your favorite
article of clothing reveals
how other people perceive you, jeans.
- Yes, very comfortable with herself.
Maybe far too comfortable with herself.
- And then your favorite body
of water is how you view sex.
- Yeah, you know what it works,
I like the sound of it.
I like it, rushing,
- What was it, connects all things?
- And it connects all things.
- I love rivers, that is very good.
- It's good, well you actually
passed with flying colors,
because a lot of times the
way that you perceive yourself
and the way other people
perceive you is wildly different.
So there's some kind of disconnect,
like I picked honey badger
as my favorite animal,
like gritty.
- Those are mean.
- I know, cause I perceive me that way,
but then everyone else
perceives me as a hoodie,
like comfortable, warm.
So I was like, oh, I
need to like do some work
on catching up on the
way I perceive myself.
- This is the coolest
thing that's ever happened
on this show.
That is so, I'm gonna
so do this to my friends
that didn't see this episode.
- It's a good way to find red flags,
if you're dating a new
person, give 'em this quiz.
If you ask 'em their favorite animal,
and they say like leech, or like
(laughs)
or like, a lot of guys will say bear,
which means like eight months of sleeping.
- Or if the girl, if it's
a girl you're lookin' at,
and she says jeans,
know that she's gonna get real comfortable
after you're married.
(laughs)
She asked me three questions,
and it was awesome.
And she does this in her
podcast, Good For You,
can she ask you three questions?
- Okay.
- Don't be nervous, I
mean you will be judged,
but don't be nervous, I'm just kidding.
- Yeah, why would say that?
- Just to freak you out.
- I'm gonna ask you three
questions, don't overthink it.
I'm gonna ask you your favorite animal,
your favorite article of clothing,
and your favorite body of water.
So what would you say
is your favorite animal?
- Uh, okay.
My favorite animal is a lion.
- Oh, good one, and what
are three characteristics
of a lion?
- That's a good one that you like.
- They're confident, they're
strong, and they're loud.
- Loud, yes, I love it.
- What would you say is your
favorite article of clothing?
It can be anything from
like a tuxedo to a hoodie
to your favorite pair of socks.
- I mean I love a good jacket.
- Yeah, like a blazer or like a jacket?
- Nah, a blue jean jacket.
- Jean jacket, that's a great one.
- Well the one I like to
wear is, I mean it's fly,
I mean that's not a characteristic.
- Yeah, it is.
- Okay, it's fly, it feels good, and
it makes my arms look nice.
(laughs)
- I look jacked.
- Jacked in my jean jacket.
- And what would you say is
your favorite body of water?
It could be a lake, a pond,
a specific river, whatever.
- Lake Michigan.
- That's so specific.
- What are some characteristics
of Lake Michigan
that you like?
- Oh, wow.
It's beautiful.
I'm a winter person, so it's
colder by the lake, usually.
- I can't wait for this.
- Where is the goin', I mean what y'all
(laughs)
- Don't panic, don't overthink it,
don't overthink it, it's very silly.
We're not attacking you.
- I gave you two, right?
- Yeah, we need one more,
just a characteristic
of Lake Michigan.
- I don't know what another
characteristic of a lake,
that's all I got.
- Are they still, are they
calm, are they, Lake Michigan is
- Huge.
(applause)
I love my audience.
I'm so happy right now.
Oh my god, I can't wait.
Okay, now tell him.
- Okay, your favorite animal
is how you perceive yourself.
You are a lion, you are
confident, you are strong,
and you are loud.
That's how you perceive
yourself, that's good.
No major red flags, no red flags.
I mean this, a little bit.
Your favorite article
of clothing is the way
other people perceive you, jean jacket.
Fly, feels good, makes my arms look nice.
(laughs)
- I think I got nice arms.
- And your favorite body of
water is how you view sex,
which is beautiful, cold, and huge.
(applause)
(laughs)
- I love it, oh my god.
Do you feel good about it?
All right, all right.
- It's pretty accurate.
- Does all that track?
- Pretty accurate.
- Cold and huge, oh my
god, I love this show, oh.